there are times that you are going to
step into a on demand or inner cage or
inner ring when someone that you know
who is better than what you are and
that's where you at the rised occasion
and you have to impose your will upon
them now I only believe in I always hear
all these coaches you like give me a
hundred ten percent you guy give me 150%
that is [ __ ]
there's only 100 percent and that's when
you give your maximum effort and there's
101 when you went beyond your
capabilities yes who was the toughest
guy you've ever faced in amateur
wrestling there we know his name was
Larry habil off four-time world champion
it was Russian yeah it wasn't uh wasn't
I think you know I went one or two at
that point in time and I knew I was
walking into match that he's better than
me and I only have one thing that I
could do to him is that I had to wear
him out because the moment I can wear
him out I won't be able to start scoring
points so so literally in the match I
knew that I was going to be losing for
how long did this match I did not know
how I would be losing but he had me
probably I don't know five six seven
eight points to nothing
by the time fatigue each time we went
out about I'm the guy that's hustle back
to Center referee's kid that's kinda
like that psychological aspect because
refugees whose world champions can move
the slope academic he's not I get on and
I'm the first guy to advance crosses
match I score the first point and it's
firing the fuel into me that's for the
second point they're getting closer
closer the fact that I IU and then I
come ahead of him and just just now he
that beat him once I beat him a couple
times and the toughest one is to beat
him in his own home country and his
hometown in front of his people because
if heard the expression of being covered
you think guys being screwed over by
points of like this being in Russia
being in his hometown I said that I
didn't just beat him I beat him and
three referees because you have to your
main referee is on the man and you have
to side judges and help them and the
crowd danger taking place the only one
look because they don't want to
acknowledge and had to score me points
so that's what said I beat him I beat
him I impose my will upon him and I beat
him because technically could I beat him
nope
and I oppose my will I rose to gauge I
gave a hundred and one percent he beat a
man you couldn't be exactly
you